SPEAKER: And then joining us
today is Helder Guimaraes.
Helder is a world renowned
sleight of hand magician.
He's received top honors
from the Academy of Magical
Arts in Hollywood, and in
2006 became the youngest ever
world champion of card magic.
The "New York Times"
has described him
as a master of illusions.
And in the review of his
last show, "Borrowed Time,"
the "Los Angeles
Times" described him
as remarkably sincere
and trustworthy
for a man committed
to deception.
His newest one man show
is "Invisible Tango,"
featuring direction by "Jurassic
World" producer Frank Marshall.
And just announced an
original soundtrack by Moby.
So Helder, thank
you for joining us.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Thank you
very much for inviting me.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
SPEAKER: So first
off, I'd like to get
into your background a bit.
How did you get
into magic, and what
drew you to sleight
of hand in particular?
HELDER GUIMARAES:
So my father was
kind of the reason why
I started in magic.
My father did and still
does magic as a hobby.
And when I was
three days old, he
took a photo of me holding
playing cards, which
is very ridiculous because it's
a three-day-old baby holding
playing cards.
And that was something that
was always a little bit
on the back of my
imagination, growing up,
knowing that that was the
first photo that anyone--
yeah, I was born in '82.
And in '82, there was no phones.
So people would not take photos
as the birth is happening.
It would take some
days to take photos.
So with three days old,
they take my first photo,
and that's with
the playing cards.
And fast forward
a couple of years.
When I was three, there
was a Christmas party
in my kindergarten.
And the owner of
the kindergarten
knew that my father did magic.
So he said, you
want to do something
for Helder's class
and the classmates?
And he said, sure, I'll do it.
And my father asked me, do
you want to do something?
And I'm three.
What do I know
about [INAUDIBLE]??
I was like, yeah, sure.
So I'll do it.
And it was fun because all
of the sudden, I'm three.
Actually, when the show
happened, I was already four.
So I was a big guy at that time.
But basically,
there was a moment
where I did something
very simple,
but for the class, for
my kindergarten class,
was like the best thing ever.
I had a box.
I would open the box.
I would show the box empty.
I would close the box.
I would say the magic words.
I would open the box, and the
box was filled with candies.
And I start throwing the
candies out for the classmate.
Not happening today.
SPEAKER: That's not
happening today.
HELDER GUIMARAES:
Not happening today.
And all of the sudden, I'm the
hero for a couple of weeks.
Like this is our friend
that makes candy appear.
That's the guy to hang out with.
And I think that was kind of
an interesting moment in terms
of memory, because I still
remember the feeling of,
in the weeks following that
party, kids coming to me
and going like,
that was amazing.
That was great.
And I just kept doing it, a
little bit without knowing
where it would take me.
It just made sense.
So I kept evolving, doing a
little bit more complex things,
doing more interesting things.
Around the age of
nine, I think nine, 10,
that's when I went like, I
don't know if this is for me.
And I stop.
And I just stopped
for two, three months.
And then I was
like, you know what?
I can't.
I really have to do this.
I didn't know why, but
there was something
that was pushing me to go back.
So I went basically
back to doing magic
without knowing
why I was doing it,
but having the feeling
that I have to do it.
And eventually, at that time--
now I'm going to go a
little bit technical--
but when you are a kid,
your hands are smaller.
So you can't really
do sleight of hand
the same way you can do
when you start growing up.
But when you are 12, you
start going to that phase.
11, 12, you start having the
ability to at least start
on that route.
And at that point,
I've seen a show.
I went to Madrid.
And I saw a show of a magician
that I've seen videos of him
before.
Not on the internet, but
on VHS, which good times.
But I've seen a bunch
of videos from him.
And now I got the
opportunity to see him live.
And he was amazing.
Because he was still alive.
His name is Juan Tamariz.
He had a bunch of
TV shows in Spain.
But all his work revolves
around playing cards
and the sense of humor.
And that for me just all of
the sudden made complete sense.
And I went like, this is it.
I always loved humors.
I always loved comedians.
I loved magic.
I said, I know this is it.
I don't want to be him, but I
know that these two things are
going to be part of my journey.
And so then I start
to focus on playing
cards and sleight of hand.
And then it evolved from there.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
Thank you.
And then so--
HELDER GUIMARAES: I give
really long answers.
So just for you to know, next
time you ask me something,
just be careful.
SPEAKER: Duly noted.
So then [INAUDIBLE] going
from just magic as a hobby
to professional magic.
So in 2006, you won the
World Championship of Magic.
And that's what kind
of launched your career
into professional magic.
Also, from what I've heard,
there was a bit of controversy
there.
They didn't believe your
performance was possible.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Yes.
SPEAKER: It's amazing.
So yeah, can you
tell a little more
how you then became a
professional at magic, I guess?
HELDER GUIMARAES: Well, that's
actually a very short answer.
Basically, you become
a professional at magic
when you get paid to do
it on a regular basis.
SPEAKER: OK. [? Fascinating. ?]
HELDER GUIMARAES:
Now, you tell me--
I think what you want to
know is how I kind of went
into that direction.
So I think since I'm 16, 17,
I kind of go like, I really
want to be a magician.
That's what I want to be.
You never know if it's possible
or not, especially growing up
in Portugal.
It's not necessarily
the country that
is best known for magic or to
be able to live comfortably
from just doing magic.
So in my head, I
always knew that if I
wanted to become a
magician, I would
have to search for a more
international career.
And one of the ways of
starting that career,
I knew it would be to
win a prize at the World
Championship of Magic,
because that would just
trigger a lot of invitations
and people trying to hire you.
So I knew that.
So a few years before, actually
four years before that,
I went to theater school.
Because I knew that
was another thing,
is that in the
journey to find, let's
say, my path, all
of the sudden I
randomly encounter myself
doing theater and doing
theater workshops.
And it makes sense to me to
combine all those things--
humor, theater, and magic.
And so I have to
go to university.
Actually, the first
university I went to
was for computer science.
So I could have actually
been here, but seated there.
But I really don't know how you
guys spend so much time sitting
in front of computers.
The first year I went to
university in computer science,
we had group tasks
that we had to do
and with a group of four people.
And three of them
would be sitting
in front of the screen working,
and I would be making jokes
to entertain them.
That's basically my
first year in college.
And then I went, you know what?
Maybe I shouldn't be doing this.
And I really had a talk with
my father and my mother.
And I said, I know
I can do this.
But I am not going to
be happy, and I'm not
going to be able to
do this professionally
for the rest of my life.
So I really want to
go and study theater,
because I think it
can help with magic.
Which for my father loves magic,
my mother loves magic as well.
But as a father and mother,
they were very worried
about my future.
So they really were like, if
he wants to be a magician,
and his backup plan
is theater, you're not
making right choices.
But they finally
heard me, and they
understand I was going
to pursue it anyway.
So we made a pact.
And the pact was, you
go to theater school.
You have four
years to finish it.
That's the degree length.
So you have four
years to finish it.
After the fourth year,
you have one year
to become fully independent.
If you can't do that, you
go back to computer science,
and you finish the degree.
And I go like, deal.
So I went to theater school.
Those are the four years.
I've learned a lot.
I've met other people that
were very like minded,
not magician wise,
but they were trying
to combine different things
with theater and performance art
and dance, for example.
And so all of the
sudden, I find myself
that I'm in a group
of people that I can
grow up with and learn from.
During those four years,
I start doing small shows
around my own town.
I got a lot of stage time.
That was a very helpful thing.
I know this is a long
answer, but I warned you.
SPEAKER: You did.
HELDER GUIMARAES:
There was a place that
was doing a lot of theater
shows and comedy shows,
but they had no magic show.
And a friend of mine was
working one of the comedy shows,
and he said, you should
talk with this guy
to see if he wants to
have you work there.
OK.
I went there.
I said, I'm a magician.
I would love to be able
to bring a show here.
And he was like, eh,
we've had a magician.
We really don't want magic.
And I was like, OK,
how many music shows
do you have here per month?
Six, seven?
And then I go, like, if you
had one bad music concert,
would you stop doing music?
And he kind of understood.
So he brought me,
and I did a show.
It was a room for 120 people.
I think I had like
40 or 45 people.
But I did a good show.
He liked it.
People liked it.
He said come back with
the same show next month.
So I brought the same show.
Next month we had
like 60 people.
And he said, well, if
you want to come back,
you have to bring
a different show.
But I'll give you two
dates on the same month.
So the next month, I
create a full one hour
show for the venue, different
than the one before.
We did two dates.
And he said, OK, bring the same
show back to the next month.
OK, so now I'm doing the
same show four times.
The fifth month, he tells me,
I can give you four dates,
but you have to change
the show every month now.
And I was like, you know what?
Let's do it.
So for two years, every month I
was doing a different one hour
performance.
And so that just give me
a lot of stage time doing
what I like, creating things.
So it just made me really
think about magic in a way
that I still think
today, but it helped
me just develop a lot of--
you have no time
to make judgments
if things are in the right way.
So sometimes you get on
stage, and you get really
awkward moments.
But that was the time.
That was the time to do it.
That was the right
moment to do it.
So those are the two years prior
to the World Champion of Magic.
So I really was very comfortable
when it came to go there
and just do 10 minutes.
Because basically, that's
what you have to do.
So I've been doing
one hour shows
different for two years almost.
So 10 minutes seemed like,
I think I can do this.
But I wasn't super confident
that I'm going to go there,
and I'm going to win.
I wasn't confident on that.
I just knew that I could
select 10 really good minutes
to go there and have an impact.
So that's what I did.
I start working on the
routine a year before.
I had the concept of
what I wanted to do.
I started developing it.
I went to a couple of
competitions, one in Spain,
where I actually won
the prize as well,
and another one in England,
where I didn't even place.
Which is fine.
That's how things are.
And then I go to the
World Championship in 2006
in Sweden, Stockholm.
I go inside of the room--
well actually, five
minutes before there
was this moment
where technically I
should be extremely nervous,
but I was extremely calm.
And I don't even
know why, because I
didn't have that much
experience at the time.
But I just had this moment
where it's like, you know what?
Just have fun.
Just go out there, have fun.
So I entered the room.
I would say that from--
so it's 3,000
magicians watching you.
Although the room for what I
do-- because I do it close up,
the room I think maybe would
sit 200 people I would say.
But there were
monitors broadcasting
to other rooms and outside.
So from those 200 people,
maybe 20 people knew who I was.
So I got in the room.
I get a nice round of applause.
People welcomed me.
I go.
I don't remember
anything I've done.
So in my head, it was just
like, fuck it [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know.
And all I know is at the end,
I'm having a standing ovation.
And I'm coming out of that room.
And as I walk outside, I
have people coming to me
and go like, what the
fuck just happened?
And it was just this
very surreal moment
because what I was at
that moment didn't change.
That was who I was.
But all of the sudden, there
were 3,000 magicians that knew
my name, that 10
minutes before didn't.
And that was kind
of an eye opener,
that sometimes it's
not who you are,
but it's how people see you
that really changes and makes
an impact.
Two days after that, they
announced the winners.
And actually I knew I won before
they announced, because there
is this moment at the end of the
convention where the winners go
on stage, and they
perform for everyone.
And normally they
have everyone that
got more than 80 points
on score to perform.
So even if you
have more than 80,
it doesn't mean
you are the first.
Because if in your category
two people have more than that,
one is first, and the
other one is second.
But in my category,
I was the only one
that got more than 80 points.
So when they
announced the names,
it was very clear
that oh, I've won.
I wasn't even in the
room when they did that.
So my parents were there.
So they heard it.
And they came out running
looking for me on the halls
of the Convention Center.
And I'm just walking with
a deck of cards in my hand,
just walking.
And all of a sudden
I see my mother--
my father wasn't there--
my mother running with a bunch
of other Portuguese people
around her going like, you won!
You won!
And I'm like, what happened?
I'm not aware.
I think tomorrow is
the award ceremony.
So I'm like, in my head
it's like, what happened?
No, you're going to
go to the final gala.
So you won.
You are the only one--
and so someone
kind of blocks me,
and explains to
me what happened.
And I was like, oh.
And all of a
sudden, that dream--
because to be honest
with you, I never
wanted to have the title,
World Champion of Magic.
That didn't matter to me.
But there were other
people in that list
of winners that were
mentors of mine,
and people I really admired.
And so for me, it
was more I made
the list with people I admire.
And so when I realized that, I
was so happy and really nervous
because now you have to perform
as the World Champion of Magic.
So it's a very
different stake now.
But everything went fine.
And so after that, I start
having calls and emails
about going to Japan,
Australia, United States.
My first travel to
the United States
was because I won that prize.
And I got booked
to do shows here.
So another very long answer.
SPEAKER: No, that's good.
That's why we're here.
They don't want to hear me talk.
So getting back to your shows--
and sounds like you're very
practiced creating shows--
much of what you
do, sleight of hand,
it's very up close, very
personal, as opposed to you're
on a stage making
cars disappear.
So how does that impact
the design of your shows,
or what kind of performances
you choose to create?
HELDER GUIMARAES: It's just the
type of thing I'm attracted to.
I've always loved--
since I saw that show
I mentioned in Madrid, I
really like the interaction
with the audience.
I really like the
fact that I never
know what the audience is
going to do when I ask them.
Even if it's a simple
thing or common gesture,
just as pick a card.
If I've told you all the
answers I've got from just that.
You have the plain one,
which is just people actually
go like, OK, let's collaborate.
Other people go like, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
I-- and then they start
like just messing around.
You never know.
And that for me is
really exciting.
Because that's kind of life.
You know?
You never know.
So I love that my shows have
that interaction component.
Then there is the part of me
loving playing cards per se.
I love the object.
It's the symbolic side of
it, the fact that it evolved
and through ages, but got
to a point where now a deck
of cards, it's what it is.
And it's never going
to change again.
It's almost like a
perfect object in itself.
And the variety
of things you can
accomplish with
that unique object,
that's the other part
that attracts me.
And so all those
things combined end up
making me want to
design my experiences
around those things.
A deck of cards, which means
that either you have a camera
and projection, and then you can
have a bigger audience watching
you.
And I prefer not to, because
I think the camera always
distance a little bit people
from the actual experience.
So that means that
you have to design
the experience for people
to be able to be near you
and be able to see it.
And then the interaction part.
I don't want to be on a stage
where I can't actually have
someone touch what I'm doing.
So all those things
combined make that--
I could have a car
on stage, but that
would be the full stage
would be the size of the car.
So it would not
be very practical.
So I just want that
proximity to be part of it.
And of course, that makes that--
the next step about
it is, you end up
deciding on things
that are very personal.
And you end up telling stories
that are part of your life,
and stories that can
make the audience
relate to who you
are as a performer.
And all those things combine
with my background in theater
and me liking the
sense of humor,
end up me mixing
all those things
and just doing all the
things I like together.
I'm very excited
about every time
I'm creating a new
show, because I get--
I think it's where
I feel more myself.
I can't say I'm a shy
person, but I'm not
as overt or as expansive
as I am on stage,
when I'm out off stage.
I have a bunch of funny
stories of people meeting me
after shows and not realizing
it's me, because they go, how
can you be the same
person that goes on stage
and says all those things
and is so open about it,
and then in here,
in the table, you
are the only person
that was not speaking?
And that is something
that changes me a bit,
is when I go on stage, I
just become more comfortable.
And I can't really explain why.
SPEAKER: Makes sense.
And so you described
yourself as a storyteller.
And many of your shows,
you like to explore themes.
"Invisible Tango"
is about mystery.
Your last one, "Borrowed
Time," was about memory.
So how does magic help
you tell the stories
that you want to tell?
HELDER GUIMARAES:
I don't think magic
helps necessarily
tell the story,
but gives it a perspective on
those themes and on who I am.
And this is something
that it's easy to relate,
but it's not necessarily
easy to explain.
I look at things around
me as illusions or magic.
So I'm always trying
to understand, where
is something I'm not seeing?
Or how I am seeing this, but
actually if I go to that angle,
it looks different.
I do that every 10
minutes in my life.
So that's something I'm just
interested in, how people craft
realities so that
you think it's real,
but it's actually
what someone else did
for you to believe it's real.
Not going further, but just
look at politics and how that
works on that specific area.
So that happens in every
single thing in our life.
And we just don't think
too much about that.
I like to think about that.
So when I approach those
subjects, like memory
for example, or
mystery, I try to see it
from the angle of a
magician looking at it.
And so magic just is
a language that allows
me to communicate those ideas.
And because I incorporate other
things, like humor and theater,
I can explore different
sides of the same theme,
according to those
different languages,
and create kind of
a unique moment.
But for me, magic is not
different than theater
or comedy.
It's just an artistic
language that allows
you to express a point of view.
And eventually, my shows
have a point of view
that is mine, because
I'm the one creating
them and performing them.
But I also always want the shows
to be open to interpretation
so that whenever you bring
your own vision to what
you're seeing, you
can make a decision.
Or at least--
I heard one time someone,
a plastic artist,
that was saying, I
want people to come out
of seeing my work with more
doubts than when they got in.
And I don't
necessarily want people
to be doubting all
their life when
they go to see a show of mine.
I think that's kind of
not very productive.
But if you can question one
little thing in your life,
that the next day you have to
make a decision [INAUDIBLE]
you know what?
Maybe there is something
here for me to think
that I've never thought about.
I'm happy with that.
If you go out of my
show, and you go,
I really had a great
time, that is something
I'm very pleased about too.
I think entertainment
for itself,
it's something very valuable.
But I always want people to
take something out of the show
when they go.
And I don't want them to
go, this is the truth.
Because I don't believe
there is one truth.
So if you can just get
one question in your life
that you've never
thought before,
I would be happy about that.
SPEAKER: OK.
Interesting, thank you.
And so you touched
on this briefly.
So when you're
designing a new trick,
you're taking inspiration
from the world around you
to some extent.
For art, you can paint
what's in front of you.
Comedy you can tell
stories from your life.
How do you take your
inspiration and kind of
transform it into the deck of
cards and the actual trick?
HELDER GUIMARAES: I think it's
all a question of metaphors.
I'll give you an example of
a moment that I [INAUDIBLE]
a spectator in a
magic performance
that I think illustrates
how I see it.
And it was from actually my
mentor, or one of my mentors,
the person who I
saw when I was 12.
He has a moment in one
of his performances
where he makes a
deck of cards vanish.
And that's the moment.
He has a deck of cards.
It's between his hands.
People are grabbing him around.
And then when he opens his
hands, the deck is not there.
Sorry, when he opens his
And that for itself,
it's just a magic moment.
Everyone reacts.
And the next question
is, where the deck is.
Everyone goes for that question.
And he explores that in
a way that is not magic.
It's really theatrical.
Because he makes you believe
that the deck is going
to reappear, and it doesn't.
And then when you think, OK,
then he makes you believe again
the deck is going to reappear
in another part, and it doesn't.
And all of the sudden,
for the next five minutes,
you are reliving the
fact that the deck is not
going to come back.
And it's funny if you
think about it now.
But in the moment you live it,
it's kind of like you feel bad.
Because you go like, oh.
And you feel incomplete.
And that's what you wanted
to explore with that moment.
It's that the
audience would have
the sense of incompleteness.
So things like that is how you
can transform certain feelings
that you want to
create in your audience
and actually make it in a
show or in a performance,
and translate that
to a magic language.
And I think that's just a very
simple example to understand.
But there are other
things that you
can do with magic
along the same lines.
It's just a question of--
so like I said, what
I like about magic
is the fact that when I
interact with the audience,
I never know what
is coming back.
But also, magic happens in the
now, happens in the moment.
That's one of the
big differences
between a theater play in a
common sense and a magic show.
Because in a theater
play, you understand
there is this time line that
people are representing.
And at one point, you
get in, and you actually
want to know what happens
next in the story.
But you know that they are
representing something else.
In magic, if I am talking with
you, I am talking with you.
It's not like the character
that is talking with you.
And the same thing
with the moment.
This is not
representing something.
This is happening now.
And that moment where
you share the same space
with an audience,
and you can actually
talk with them in that
moment, and they know that
is happening then, and
it's never happening again.
Because if it happens
again, it's always
going to be slightly different.
That is something that--
I like that.
So I like to use those moments
in the show to actually create
feelings and
sensations and pushing
a little bit the boundary of
what can be done with magic.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
So pivoting a little bit to
a different kind of magic,
the magic of the big screen.
You recently got done-- you were
a consultant on "Ocean's 8."
Can you tell me
a little bit more
about the role you played there?
HELDER GUIMARAES: Yes.
So I'm in New York.
I'm doing a show.
And all of the
sudden, I got an email
from someone who
watched the show saying,
we're doing this movie.
And we have a part of the script
that we would like for someone,
some people that are
related to deception,
to read about and make sure
that we got this right.
And at that point, I had
no idea what movie it was.
So then I got on the
phone, and then I
realized it's an "Ocean's
Eleven" spin-off with women.
It's going to be
called "Ocean's 8."
I know nothing about the cast.
I didn't even know the
movie was in production.
But the movie was going to be--
the headquarters for the
movie shot was in New York.
So I basically met with the
director, the co-writer--
because the director also
wrote-- so the director,
the co-writer, and a producer.
And we basically have
a brief conversation
about that small
part of the script.
And I explained, you know what?
In real life, this can be
done like this, or like this,
or like this.
And something that they thought
could just happen in one way,
I gave them like seven or
eight different options
of how that can actually
happen in real life.
And it's about a con, which
is something I really like.
Not as a practitioner,
but as someone--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
HELDER GUIMARAES:
Yeah, but I just find
the psychology of con
artists very fascinating.
So I've studied it for a time.
And so when I got
there, I go, yeah,
it can be done like this,
or like this, or like this.
And all of the sudden, it's
like I opened the door for them.
Like we didn't even know
that that was possible.
So they invited me at that
point not just for that scene,
but they said, you know what?
It would be great if you
could work with the actresses
on helping them understand how
the psychology of deception
works.
And so that's why
I got brought in.
And so then that's
when I found out
that I was going to be working
with Sandra Bullock and Cate
Blanchett, teaching them
some sleight of hand,
and teaching them the psychology
of pickpocket and things
like that.
So they brought me
basically on that role.
And so it was just a very
surreal experience to meet,
all of the sudden
be teaching all
these amazing
actresses something.
And then I got to be on
the floor of the filming
on a couple of scenes.
And that was it.
It was really fun.
SPEAKER: And so correct
me if I'm wrong.
So also you actually
taught Sandra Bullock
how to pick pockets and
set her on the director.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Yes.
So I don't know if you
guys saw the movie.
SPEAKER: Not yet.
HELDER GUIMARAES:
But there is a scene
in the movie where she
actually does not pick pocket,
but does something that
is pickpocket related.
And they just wanted to--
of course, in a movie,
it's all made up.
But they just wanted
to have the feeling of,
if we're going to do
this in real life,
how would this be done?
And so basically we staged
that moment to look like,
yes, this could actually
happen in real life.
So yes, so that's true.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And so you mentioned briefly,
but in a movie, you have cuts.
You have editing.
You don't actually have
to pick the pocket.
So then does having you
bring your expertise in kind
of physical misdirection,
sleight of hand,
just help the audience stay
more engaged or believable,
or what does that bring?
HELDER GUIMARAES:
I think it's just
a question of that, is
like how can you shoot this
so that this looks real,
but works on camera?
And I think my role on
a couple of the moments
were that, was like,
how can we shoot this
so that it looks good on camera,
and it's actually close to what
would happen in real life?
It's less about make--
and this movie was a very
particularly [INAUDIBLE],,
because I'm not doing
actually magic to the movie,
or not creating magic to
be happening in the movie.
It's more a question of, how
would this happen in real life?
Let's try to reproduce
this in a movie sequence.
And shot it in a way that
story wise it makes sense.
People can follow that.
I don't know if anyone
here saw the movie,
but there is an opening scene
where she goes in a store,
and she steals a
couple of things.
How that is done tells
a story to the audience,
that when the moment
of the con happens,
the audience can be on her side.
And if the audience
is on her side,
the reaction is much better
than if they are still
figuring out what is happening.
So those little
things, they really
matter when you're
making a movie.
And so I try to help as
best as to my knowledge
to things like that.
SPEAKER: Wonderful.
Thank you very much.
So I'd just like to remind
everybody, his new show
premieres at the Geffen
Playhouse in May.
So we have some time
to take some questions
from the audience.
So just--
HELDER GUIMARAES: Yes, I would
just like to say something.
So I'm really happy to be here.
Thank you very much for inviting
me, before we go into Q&A.
But because of that, I
talked with the Geffen,
and basically they made a
promo code that is googletalks.
So if you go on the website,
and you want to buy tickets,
and you put googletalks,
you get 20% off discount.
SPEAKER: Does that work if
we already bought tickets?
HELDER GUIMARAES: I don't know.
That you have to
talk with the Geffen.
I don't think that is
retroactive things.
SPEAKER: Oh.
Thank you.
HELDER GUIMARAES: My pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Just raise your hands
if you have any questions.
We'll fastball the mic at you.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Nice throw.
AUDIENCE: So thanks for coming.
It was a super interesting talk.
So feel free to tell
me to just go away.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Go away.
AUDIENCE: Well, OK.
HELDER GUIMARAES:
I'm not joking.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm kidding.
Of course I'm kidding.
No, you can sit down.
Sit down.
That's ridiculous.
That's just ridiculous.
AUDIENCE: How do you figure out
just the technical mechanics
of a new trick that
you're developing?
I've obviously never
been in this space,
so I don't understand,
like I want
to be able to pull the
correct card out of a deck,
or I want to do this or
that, or this other thing.
So what's the general process
of one, deciding what exactly
do you want to do
onstage, and then two,
how are you going to
go about executing it?
HELDER GUIMARAES: It's
a really good question.
I don't know if I
have an answer per se,
but I'll try to do my best.
So most of the things
I decide to do onstage
come out from stories,
come out from something
that appeals to me on
the story side of it,
or in the moment I want to
create with the audience.
So that's the reason why
I decide to do something.
How do I end up creating those?
So there is a lot of--
magic has a very rich
history of people
that created and decided
to share with other people
their creation.
So you are always studying, and
you are always learning things,
that eventually one day you
can go like, you know what?
I can apply that concept.
So there are a bunch
of concepts that I
would say that they are
finite, in terms of they
are limited to a certain amount.
But then the application of
those concepts, it's infinite.
It just goes with your
imagination and your ability
to actually implement those
concepts in different ways.
So when I have a problem--
and I really like to start
with problems that I go,
I have no idea
how I can do this.
So now, it's almost like,
this is the illusion.
Because I know that
what I'm trying to do,
it's actually impossible.
So now it's, how can I
create this illusion?
And now I kind of start
going back, step by step.
If I want to reach this
moment, what would I
have to do right before this?
Maybe this, maybe
this, maybe this.
And then you end up
with, I would say, maybe
sometimes seven, eight,
sometimes more, sometimes less,
basically solutions.
And then you actually
start trying them.
And you go like,
OK, let me try this.
No, there is something
missing here.
Or actually it's
not that deceptive.
Because then you have
to make that judgment.
It's like, is the
audience going to be
deceived with this idea or not?
So it's all those
things combine.
And on the side, you always
have the story going like,
that really does
not match the story.
So this method is
completely discarded,
because it's not faithful to
the story I want to convey.
This one is closer.
OK.
So now this one is
something I can work on,
and I can develop on top of
that basic idea or first idea.
And then eventually, you come
up with moments and pieces
that you're proud of,
or that you think work.
But at the end of the
day, you have to do it.
And if the audience
says no, you go, OK.
You just go home.
Then you really go home.
But it's those things
combine that is
kind of the process to get
on stage and do something.
AUDIENCE: So you tell
stories and send messages
in lots of different,
I'll say, audiences,
like there's 50
people here or so.
You do shows where
it's 25 people.
The Geffen's 120 or something.
A TED Talk is a lot more,
and then social media's
however many.
How do those different spaces--
how do you decide what
story you want to tell,
or how you pick the words?
How do you decide how
to convey the message
in these different environments?
And how does that
change, particularly
when you're speaking
to a larger audience?
HELDER GUIMARAES: It
does because you always
have to adapt the show you do
to the room you're playing in.
And of course, the more
you learn how to do it,
the more easy it is to
create moments of intimacy
in larger spaces.
In that sense, I've--
so the last show I've done in
Portugal was for 900 people.
And at that point, it's not
an intimate show no longer.
But it doesn't mean it can't
be an intimate experience
for people.
You just have to
do certain choices
in terms of scenic design
and in terms of text
and in terms of-- for
example, in that show
there is a camera that
projects the top of the table,
and there's a big screen.
But you can't overuse it.
Because all of the
sudden, if you overuse it,
people feel that they are always
seeing things on the screen.
And don't feel that.
So you have to decide
and craft the show more
around the technical challenges
that you're going to have.
And I think the
bigger the space is,
the more you have
to do it that way.
In a smaller space,
where everyone
can observe you and
be closer to you,
then it's the story that
really drives more the creation
of everything.
That's why I prefer that.
It's because then I can really
focus on what I want to say
and how I want to
tell the story.
How I go about
selecting the stories,
it comes from life
experiences and moments
I am living and doubts I have.
It's not that rare
that I find myself
doing a show to try
to answer to something
I don't have an answer.
Like now.
This show I'm doing,
it's about how
we deal with mystery in a
world that has information
at the fingertips, and
that people are not
willing to not know something.
How many conversations
do you have
per month where all of a
sudden you have a doubt,
and immediately you take the
phone to answer that doubt?
That's a mechanism that in
certain cases makes sense.
In others, you
should not do that.
You should pull a little bit
from behind of your brain
and try to deal with
that in a different way.
Because it can be very useful--
and actually, saying this
at Google just feels weird.
[LAUGHTER]
But one thing is
the ability of being
able to have that information.
I think that's great.
How we value that information
and how we use it,
and how we leave
space for mystery--
because mystery can be so much
important in our life as well--
that balance, it's something
that I personally am always
struggling to understand.
And I believe other
people probably too.
So the show deals a
little bit with that.
And it's just a story
in the perspective
from my side of the table
of maybe how we can all
incorporate a little bit
more mystery in our lives.
AUDIENCE: So I will
say having gotten
to have the experience of
sitting with you in table
and being a participant is
something that will always
stick with me.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And one of
the things I realized
that helped contribute
to that sense of wonder
is the fact that your
style of performance
was something that I had no
idea what was going to happen.
But there are, of
course, other people
who in their performances
set up an expectation where,
for example, if it's a
prediction or something, where
you sort of know what
the end goal is, right?
Where you know what
they're going to do,
and the question is, the
setup is that it's impossible,
but they're somehow
still going to do it.
What do you think draws you
towards the other style, where
there isn't a clear
expectation, where someone
has no idea what's
going to happen,
that you haven't necessarily
set up that oh, this
is the thing I'm going
towards, and instead
you just surprise them?
HELDER GUIMARAES: I actually
use both when I'm doing a show.
I use moments like
you're saying,
like setting up an expectation
and trying to deliver that.
I just like the fact
that the audience
is less worried about the
end and more interested
in the journey.
So that's why I prefer a little
bit the surprise style, as you
said, has to do with that, the
idea of, where is this going?
Let's live this story together.
It's more on that side
that my preference takes.
But in a one hour show, you
have to kind of play with that.
There is actually an
article in the magic world
that talks about
surprise versus suspense,
and how that affects one, the
creation, other, the audience
experience of the show.
And I think both are valuable.
And I think both play
a part on my work.
I really like the
fact that I'm sharing
the journey with the
audience at the same time,
instead of telling
you, by the way,
I already know where
this is going to end.
And so now you're just
watching, but you know
where this is going to end.
I like that part to also be
kind of unclear and unknown,
so that when it happens,
you go, wait a minute.
I love that type of--
it's a game almost with the
audience that you're playing.
And I like that game
of the audience almost
being a detective
during the process,
being like, why
is he doing this?
Why?
Oh.
I like that moment.
But to be honest, it's
just because of that.
I like the audience to
be in this boat with me
in terms of journey.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So when you are
watching other performers,
is it easy for you to
deconstruct their tricks
and illusions, or
are you also amazed?
And are there any illusions that
have stumped you to this day
that you still can't
tell how they did it?
HELDER GUIMARAES: It's hard to
let go the magician side of it.
I admit it.
So when I'm seeing
a performance,
it's almost like I'm
seeing with a double brain.
I'm trying to enjoy it
without thinking too much.
But then there are
certain moments
that definitely
click, just because I
know how things are done.
So all of the sudden,
it's really hard
just to let it go completely.
That said, that
doesn't mean that I
don't appreciate a performance
when it's well done.
In fact, I always say this
as a comparison situation.
If you play the piano,
and you go to a concert,
and someone is playing a
recital or something like that,
and they are playing, and
you know how to play piano,
you are listening to the
melody, but you are also
listening to their
choices and how
they decide to do certain
parts quicker or with more
strength or all that.
And so when I'm seeing a
magic performance normally,
I'm also seeing those
choices and seeing
where those choices will
make the audience arrive
in terms of impossibility.
And so I really appreciate--
and sometimes it's even
more beautiful to be
able to see the audience
reaction and also that.
But there have been
a couple of times--
I can't say that it's
the common thing--
but where all of the
sudden, I'm in a moment,
and I don't understand
how something happens,
and I just love it.
Because I don't have that
reaction that many times.
So when I have it,
I really cherish.
And I really-- the
only reason for me
after to try to find
an answer to that
is if I find any
valuable on that
to be able to use on my work.
But there have been, I would say
that two or three cases, where
I've seen something that
I go, what I'm seeing
has no relation to
my type of work.
So I just prefer not to know.
And I really don't.
Because I don't have that
many moments like that.
So I really cherish those.
So I really don't want to know,
unless it can move something
forward on my work.
And then I probably will
search for an answer.
But there are things
I really don't know.
I may have a sense,
an idea, but that's
different than actually knowing.
That's a very
interesting difference
between being a magician,
not being a magician,
and seeing a magic show.
If you see a magic show,
and you kind of find out 10%
of what you're seeing--
let's suppose what
you call the trick.
I really hate the word trick.
Dogs do tricks for me.
But like I call them
pieces or repertoire,
something like that.
But imagine you're seeing a
magic piece, and you find 10%.
If you are an audience
member and you
know nothing about magic, you go
like oh, I know how he did it.
And you just know 10%.
If I am a magician, and
I'm seeing the same thing,
and I know 90%, I go
like, yeah, I really
don't know how he did it.
Because I am aware that I'm
missing those extra 10%.
So it's a very interesting
thing how we relate
to knowing or not knowing.
If we know a lot, we also
know what we don't know.
If we know very little,
we think we know
more than we actually know.
It's true.
It's true in any case.
And with magic, you
can say that to a test.
I've been in so many
interesting conversations
after shows of mine
with friends that
go like, I really
liked your show,
but I figured this one out.
And I just go like, oh really?
And so I go down the road
with them and go like,
so tell me how I do it.
And they start
going step by step.
And I know there is a hole in
the middle of the conversation
where they're just going to go
like, oh, I really don't know.
But I led them to that hole.
Very like, oh really?
[INAUDIBLE]
And this-- oh, oh yeah,
I really don't know.
OK, so shut up next time.
Just shut up.
And that's OK.
To be honest with you, I'm not--
if people find
out, they find out.
I always say this as
a joke, but it's true.
I'm very privileged
of doing what I do,
because I bring joy to
people, and I make them happy,
and it's entertaining.
What I do falls
in the bright side
of life, which for me I'm very
fortunate to be part of it.
This is not like you're
curing a life death
situation on a patient.
And if you fail, that is tough.
If I fail something
or if you find out,
life goes exactly in
the same direction.
So I'm not that uncomfortable
if people find out.
I always try my
best to make sure
that they have the
mystery for their life.
That's my goal.
But it's so funny to lead
people into these conversations,
and having them realize that
they actually don't know.
It's just really funny for me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
We have time for maybe
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us a little bit
about how you practice?
And I'm sure at
your stage, you've
mastered the double lift.
But are you still doing
it 100 times a day,
or what does your practice
routine look like?
HELDER GUIMARAES: No, I
don't do it 100 times a day,
because it's boring.
But you definitely practice the
same way that you would say--
there is a difference between
getting the skill to the level
you want to get it,
and then keeping
the skill at that level.
So to keep the skill, you don't
have to technically practice
that much.
But you still have to
do it on a regular basis
and consistent basis.
But I'm always trying to
improve certain things
or invent new skills
or invent new things.
So I'm always focused
more on that side
than necessarily keeping
the skill level where I am.
Because doing that
ends up protecting
what I've accomplished before.
But you have to do it every day.
So every day I have a few hours
that I just spend on a table,
what we say shuffling
cards, which is actually not
shuffling cards.
But just doing a
bunch of things.
And finding things.
I'm always finding new
interesting details that can
take things to the next step.
But you do that.
You do that in
front of a mirror.
You do that to close friends
when you want to do something.
Normally I'm at dinner with
friends, and if I want to--
I normally don't like to
just do things per se,
but if I want to
practice something,
all of the sudden, all I have
to do is take the deck of cards
and put it on the table,
because someone is going
to ask me to do something.
And then I go, OK, that's a
good chance to practice that,
because it's a safe environment.
So you find those moments
to do things like that,
and to find the
audience reactions.
So that then you can
incorporate those
in longer pieces and
moments like a show,
like I'm doing now.
But yes, definitely, you have
to keep practicing every day.
Unless you want to quit.
And then it would be
fine not do anything.
SPEAKER: OK, I think that's
all the time we have.
Thank you, Helder,
so much for coming
to spend some time with us.
HELDER GUIMARAES: Thank you
very much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]